a lot of hardcore Dexter fans in the
crowd tonight people love this show and
who'd have thought that the main
character is a serial killer and people
love him yeah they loved well they say
he's America's favorite serial killer
like there's a list of 12 of us yeah
I've looked at that list and you really
are my favorite most of the least
favorite and the middle child too but
you know this thing has has blown up not
just in this country worldwide
I mean you yeah there's a lot of
countries you can't go to now because
they they all know Dexter yeah a lot of
it is on the free-to-air networks in
other countries so the ratio of people
who recognise me is actually higher like
I just went to Istanbul Turkey I was in
the Old Market the first line of the
first episode of Dexter his his voice
services tonight's the night you know
and he's doing this thing yeah and I was
walking through and there was this
little teenage girl and she was like
very short Dexter tonight fantastic this
is a sign that you've really made it is
this Turkey what I'm about to show this
is this is the reason I went was because
of GQ magazine you're on the cover of GQ
magazine in Turkey and they love this
photo
[Applause]
have won arrests I love that pose right
there yeah that's if I'm gonna be killed
by a serial killer I want it to be this
guy right hi welcome come on in now cut
your head off in a moment there's some
pajamas yeah they went crazy for they
put you on the cover of their GQ and
then the photo shoot is quite odd can we
just take a look at some of these photos
like I don't know what there you are
you're not really Dexter here are you
playing a different character you know
you show up to these photo shoots or at
least in my experience I do and they the
people in the fashion world call it a
story what's the story and this story
that stories you have bad breath yeah I
don't know what's going on oh yeah it's
like oh you're some sort of
independently wealthy gentleman of some
indiscriminate European heritage who
like to dress up three or four times a
day and abuse your maid I said great
let's do it I think we have another one
here I don't know what's going on here
there you are what it's getting kind of
erotic I think or not
and it means definitely it's probably
earlier the days you know what this mean
I don't know what happened here I mean I
was there I was wearing that suit I did
have that head on my shoulders but that
I mean the photographer's great but that
looks like a Photoshop I don't
understand it really does your head does
not look like it matches the rest of
your body